let me ask you
some advice to put on your profound hat
what uh there's a bunch of young folks
who listen to this
thing for no good reason whatsoever
uh undergraduate students maybe high
school students
maybe just young folks a young at heart
uh looking for
uh the next steps to taking life what
advice would you give to a young person
today about
life maybe career but also life in
general
get good at some stuff well get to know
yourself right
but get good at something that you're
actually interested in you have to love
what you're doing to get good at it
you really got to find that don't waste
all your time doing stuff that's just
boring or bland or numbing
right don't let old people screw you
well people get talked into doing all
kinds of [ __ ] and wrapping up huge
student
you know student debts and like there's
so much crap going on
you know and then drains your time and
drains yeah the eric weinstein you know
thesis that you know the older
generation will like oh
yeah they're trapping all the young
people i think there's some truth to
that
yeah sure just because you're old
doesn't mean you stop thinking i know
lots of really original
yeah old people i'm an old person
so um but you have to be conscious about
it you can fall into the rats and then
do that i mean when i hear young people
spouting opinions that sounds like they
come from fox news or cnn i think
they've been captured by
groupthink and memes and supposed to
think on their own
you know so if you find yourself
repeating what everybody else is saying
you're not going to have a good life
like like that's not how the world works
it may be
it seems safe but it puts you at great
jeopardy for
well being boring or unhappy
you